[Music]
Aviv shapira thank you so much for
joining me a startup Nation United uh a
series that is now deeply um deeply in
my heart the way that we as a startup
Nation came together October 7th a
devastating day but out of it a a
unified a unifying moment H not just
socially but also in terms of uh also in
terms of our ability to uh to you know
Foster um Innovation and be and help our
individual contributions with the work
that we're doing so obviously you're
serial entrepreneur you're the COO of a
company called extend which I'm also an
honor honored to be a very small part of
but um what you know one of the most
amazing things that I've had the
privilege of seeing from the sidelines
is how relevant your work is in aiding
in the context of the conflict so I'm
excited to now 64 days into the war um
recap a little bit of what's been
happening with you over these last 64
days um and I and I want to understand
even before we do that maybe just a few
words about extend and yourself just for
the context and then I want to dive into
October 7th okay so a few words about
myself uh so I'm an aerospace engineer I
worked many years in the defense
industry and in generally in robotics
and uh uavs H the last uh 15 years in
startups uh where my my most famous
startup is replay Technologies which was
acquired by Intel after winning two am
Awards and eventually that was the the
Kickstart for extend how do how do we
create a technology that allows people
to actually access remote places uh with
virtual reality technology but into
robots and drones and not into sports
like the previous company uh extend
started actually it's a very interesting
story to uh recap um you know extend as
a gaming company allowing anyone to fly
a race drone that flies 150 kilm per
hour for gaming purposes and the first
thing we did with this gaming uh let's
call it PC or MVP was to intercept Kites
and balloons in
Gaza um so you know today Gaza is
different uh you know we don't we don't
see Kites and balloons we see something
uh much more severe
unfortunately um but we are dealing with
uh the you know the the threats in 2019
and with the threats today so x0 is uh
is helping IDF to win a
the war in different in different
Evolutions um so you know what started
in 2019 as a as a balloon and kite
Interceptor became today um a leading
system allowing soldiers to actually um
uh step inside very dangerous situations
from remote using robotic technology so
essentially you don't have to uh breach
doors you can do that with drones and
robots you don't have to to uh you know
find yourself trying to clear buildings
you know with a K9 dog or or with
yourself you can do that with uh with
our equipment and um at the end of the
day we're trying to allow um soldiers
police officers security Personnel to
actually do everything that they would
uh do physically in Risk themselves but
without taking physical risks so let's
extend in a
nutshell um you know regarding uh
regarding uh extend you know October 6th
and October 7th is is a very different
company
um so before before uh the war started
we we are the company is split in half
so we have an Enterprise business
dealing with uh inspection oil and gas
renewable energy um and there is a there
is a defense business which is mostly
focused on the US market October 7th is
100% uh IDF supporting supportive
company um across all sectors of the
company and uh we basically placed all
of our efforts in order to help the IDF
it actually started with uh like a lot
of startups company helping just you
know volunteering work and and and
contributing what we can without being
paid um I guess like many others we try
to get uh donations and help wherever we
can uh but at some point after about
three four days um IDF stepped in and
said we've chosen extend as one of five
um five most important vertic and
vectors in order for IDF to win this war
um so so since then we've been very very
busy and so you know share with me just
a little bit about from from your
personal experience October 7th hits how
you know as a CEO of the startup and now
um and and how many people people are in
extend as a
company um so exent today overall is 100
people about 100 people about half on
the Civil side and half of the defense
side so yeah walk me through you know
what happens from that morning and how
how you're thinking through what what
extent role is going to be both for the
for the first part of the volunteering
part but then also commercially how do
you then actually integrate this into
extend core core business
proposition um so it's it's it's very
interesting what happened so Saturday
morning was uh you know I was on the way
surfing and it happened um I can tell
you that that Saturday evening was was
supposed to be uh we were supposed to
fly a very large team uh one team was
supposed to fly to a very big uh defense
event in the US and another team was
supposed to fly uh to close an
investment
forance um obviously both of them were
cancelled uh probably around lunchtime
we understood that uh you know uh we're
not going anywhere and that uh basically
uh uh put on hold some of our most
important uh uh tasks as the company you
know both on the fundraising side and
both on on the US market side in terms
of uh you know s selling selling our
technology to that market um so you know
after a few days ER you know after a few
days we we met with our with our normal
representatives in in in uh in the in
the mod mafat and we decided on a course
of action uh the first thing that we uh
thought about is uh you know how do we
how do we how do we take down drones you
know the drones that the war started
with drones that basically killed our
eyes and ears extan has counter drone
technology let's deal with that you know
let's start with killing drones in the
skies and uh I can tell you today um a
you know after two months we had more
than uh 10 new products issued by the
company just because we are learning
we're learning what's happening in the
field and everything that we planned
actually changed you know for example
GPS is a problem uh um you know you're
learning uh you're learning a a lot
about the enemy how do they work in
tunnels how do they work uh how do they
attack you how do they how do you defend
yourself against them so you know 10
different variations of products you
know you take something from this drone
to another robot you change uh some VR
characteristics you know everything
everything changes in Wartime and our
ability our ability to adapt is is what
made us uh succeed you're 100% company
you're initially you have a civil
Enterprise side then you have the US
defense side now you're now you have 100
people and your employees effectively
working in their own backyard right
you're you productizing in in our own
country how how what what does that
cause an organization like extend how do
you experience culturally the way that
this then changes how your employees
perceive their own day-to-day of the
company so first of all uh you know
Reserve is is is a big issue about 30%
of the compan has been been is been
summoned uh to reserve um and and entire
departments were not there on October uh
9th you know you know or October sorry
uh uh 8th when they had to go back to uh
to the office I'm talking about my whole
um uh business team H some some of the
engineering engineering team have simply
you know gone and you have to and you
have to somehow uh multiply the amount
of work that you do so you know you have
less people and more work and how do you
compensate for that so it took us about
a week to understand uh that we can
actually ask for people to return um so
about 10% of the people actually return
because we're doing H you know IDF
related work you know we're not just
like a gaming company anymore and that
really helped us uh but uh a lot of
people like myself started to do more
than one roles so I'm now in charge of
business and the CEO right so this
everyone has has another role that he
has to do
um I can tell you that uh we've received
orders in the past two months more than
the entire uh 20122 year so we are very
very busy and and we have and we and it
made a scale so you know from for
manfacturing maybe tens 10 to to 50
systems in a month we now have to
manufacture 300 to 500 in a month you
know how do you do that again with less
people so um a lot of really really uh
hard U hard uh I would say um uh growth
uh uh pains that happen like in in in in
in days in weeks uh you don't have time
to prepare for that um but because there
is a very very strong goal you know
you're helping you're helping to save
lives it's not like you know you have a
very strict deadline to make money
you're really saving lives that that
changes everything so people are working
day and night and Friday and Saturday
without without stopping yeah that's and
and I guess it there's it's a different
sense of mission right I mean it just
that's what that's what it I it sounds
like from from from your perspective
there's the you know there's you you
really do feel the the urgency from
backyard and we obviously we feel it we
feel it at home and um and so looking
forward how does that impact extend as
an organization you as a CEO what what
are your what are your thoughts looking
forward as to how this
war and extends roll in shaped extends
trajectory um I think uh it makes us
today one of the most operational
companies in our Fields um you know a
lot of companies can can sell products
for a future War we are in war you know
we are using the products every day we
saving lives we were the first drones to
enter uh you know B Fara and basically
deal with these uh terrorists and um and
we learned so much from that you know so
much and this and this is what happened
this is why we change so much in the
system just to make sure we comply for
for the next day and the next day you
know suddenly you get like software
upgrades every day and not every month
uh for me as a CEO um I think I'm
learning uh I'm learning that uh um you
know you can you can do more with less
people as long as you have
motivation um there's there are two
there are two ways to actually motivate
to to make someone do something
manipulation by telling you know by
telling someone I'm your Bros do
something or by telling him you know if
you do this you can save people's lives
um and and I think we learned that we
can do so much more with this with with
less people which is uh really
inspirational for everyone here in the
company Aviv wishing you best of luck
thank you for the great work that you're
doing thank you for the both from the
volunteering aspect but then also for
the for finding the right commercial fit
because obviously it needs to be
sustainable and it needs to you know
Foster the continued growth and
innovation of extend as a company and
will only make the Israel and our
defense stronger so it all is a circle
of win-wins so thank you very very much
and I um and I'm wishing you you and us
all best of luck thank you for the
inspiration thank you for your time bye
for now
[Laughter]
yeah